hey guys Pete peppers here and we're
going to talk about a new soft launch
title that came out and it is in the
bubble Witch Saga series it's got a
working title of Wilbur it may be the
final title we don't really know at this
point but if you're keeping track it's
bubble Witch Saga number three so it's
the permits the follow up to bubble
Witch Saga 2 which came out over a year
ago now so you can see that it's a map
based game like the like most of the
King games and these are the world I
just started playing it earlier so I'm
going to go back to the beginning and
we'll talk about some things one thing
that stood out right away about this one
is that there is sort of a boss mode
similar to jelly saga but on this in
bubble which three it is when you get
past you know an episode you play a
level versus Wilbur so
go right into the beginning in level 1
this is a bubble shooter game just like
the other bubble which saw goes not my
favorite type of game I don't play any
bubble shooters regularly to be honest
but as far as they go this one seems
cool I did play bubble witch two for a
while and I think this is you know a
little bit more interesting as far as
the mechanics go so we have you know our
normal levels here where we have to just
clear all the bubbles pretty
straightforward stuff first levels were
always really easy but that gives you a
general idea what things look like and
we'll talk about some of the other game
modes too so you see here we have
different icons on each each of the
thing so I guess the stars those will be
the one we just play which is race to
the top sort of from the other game and
then you see these ones have ghosts and
these are a little bit different this is
a brand new game mode look at how this
work compared to other ghost levels so
here it says we have to lead the ghost
upwards he sort of floats you see this
line on the screen that's gonna if we
get him to move up quicker then we clear
out the bubbles when they when they hit
this line as they scroll down they'll
get moved off so we'll just go ahead and
smash some bubbles here you can see some
of the bubbles have this glowing kind of
orb going on inside I'll show you what
that is that goes off and clears another
one and you see the the ghost he kind of
goes
pretty quickly like wherever there's a
space he finds that he doesn't go
straight up so that's kind of cool the
lines are pretty easy to follow as I
said that hit and shot one off in the
wrong direction but you could switch the
colors like you did before and I'll try
not to let go whenever I'm doing it but
you see he went around and found the way
up to the top so that is the ghost mode
it's pretty cool we'll play one more
ghost for real quick you see here we
have these um we'll see only gets to the
top but we have these orbs that are kind
of explosions so that's a new feature
here we will get to see how the line
clears it out so you guys a path up so
it all gets it out of the way and like I
mentioned these are these just use
explode there I'll hit one right here
that you can hit them with any color and
they just kind of clear out of square
kind of a cool animation there where it
all comes down
it just came out so I'm sure that
there'll be some changes as things go
along but I kind of like the animations
in the mechanics are a little bit
they're a little bit different
definitely noticeable difference between
the last game they put out so it looks
like from this if they're going to start
bringing out different versions all the
time similar to how they do it with
candy crush now here when we fill out
the Hat over here I don't know what this
guy's name is but when she filled his
hat up he gives us one of these super
shots and you can actually switch that
to but it's sort of like one of these
but you can fire so through there it's
going to clear the whole the whole thing
for us so another one of the game modes
that we saw
one click on this
is the owls and the Owls are sort of
like saving animals and the other one
except here they're color-coded so I'll
explain how that's different I can't you
know we hit red ones with the red ball
and a red bubble and the red one escapes
so here I can drop down all these but
you can see that since I hit it with a
red the yellows and the blues go and
connect with another another red and
blue or another blue yellow spot on the
board so they start to build up if you
you don't kind of take your time and
clear out the bright colors got a meter
up here counts counts them up here we
can use this to clear out blues even
though it's not blue it basically works
as any color so that comes in handy
work our way up here and once we collect
these two then that will complete this
level so the details are sort of an old
a new twist on an old favor but they're
pretty cool and then let me see if I can
go back and play him again let's see
it's a defeat welder level and this is
the last one of the first episode and
then there's another one at the end of
the second episode and so on and so
forth so Wilbur's up here he's got a
meter and we have to hit him with the
bubble so this was actually a little bit
confusing when I first played it so here
he can he can bring new ones out you
know from this centerpiece so we have to
do sword ship away at the overall
structure faster than he can bring them
back they kind of come straight back
there but I guess maybe as his meter
goes down then he has less of an ability
to be able to do
until you know obviously we're trying to
get up here to where we can get rid of
these arms I'll get those out of the way
see if you les came out that time so
here we might be able to hit them now
now we will be able if you hit the top
it doesn't bounce back down oops missed
until I accidentally shot again here we
go
that's how it works you just pick away
at the at the chain and then you can
defeat Wilber so that's that's that's
the gist of it if you like bubble
shooters will probably love this one
made a bunch of videos so that we'll
have them on the channel at least for
now and we'll see how it develops if you
got any questions leave a comment below
please like the video and subscribe to
my channel so that you can get all the
latest gameplay previews and all the
level videos for the games that we hate
we play we keep everything updated as
fast as we can we'll be talking to you
soon thanks